hello and welcome to this video playing
sneaky or pawn let's see what happens
against him this is the second game it's
funny because I know this person I know
who that is
anyway we'll see I came there is a very
solid player I do you want to play the
BOGO again such a solid player the super
solid guy never played g3 ok this key
goes d5 so you know I was thinking about
this one not not that I know it all that
well but I recently had a brief look at
this and I was not entirely sure that it
really is so terrible it's called the
snake Benoni maybe that was a
subconscious decision yeah if you play
snake your pawn you play the snake Ben
Oni I don't know let's see what happens
oh yeah this is probably critical so we
might even have some knowledge him
interesting yeah not a move that I'm
happy to see of course you can't sell
probably develop this it might happen
that it might happen that my bishop gets
sidelined here so maybe I have to take
at some some point of course my c8
Bishop is not really really good
v6 and Bishop a6 that would be quite
helpful I mean I suspect that white is
probably better him very likely he is
but one thing you have to really take
you take into into account is that if
you want to win a game do you need to
create imbalances and this is definitely
not a very balanced position now we have
bishop pair for white which is helpful
almost universally helpful but he's got
the odd the author witness even these
six you could actually call somewhat
weak Knight a5 comes into consideration
Knight to e4 is also a move that you
could think about not certain though I
would like to really get the Queen into
the plane no this is also generally
useful get this out of the diagonal yeah
maybe night night before was something
so looks an issue but didn't feel very
pressing okay um do I want to go Knight
to e4 let attacks the sex
probably not it looks a bit more
pressing ok now night it's night before
anything you can actually you could
argue that this could be not bad you
just trying to use it for Bishop before
I think trades generally are not bad for
me because because of potential
weaknesses they're okay potential
weaknesses on lies in good but he tries
to checkmate me that's really not nice
and g6 is kind of kind of shaky looking
I cannot go h6 now
maybe just six Queen f6 and I'm just
busted channel it would be it would be
would be cool yeah anyway have to do it
hmm
so might simply take them 95 is a
resource that I totally overlooked I
mean like completely overlooked which is
kind of bad
okay you know what can you do in 94
doesn't work
fortunately the long diagonal is really
really really problematic if he moves
the night maybe night h3 is strong
mm-hmm cannot move this rupee six it's
going to be really really painful I
guess they have to do it don't nothing
nothing to be done yeah I can I can give
the exchange but I still I'm in a in an
awful pin right I mean an awful pin even
g4 is probably strong that might be
strong as well yeah but
45 yet I did so it's all good of course
I cannot get the night anywhere 94 maybe
could be helpful even Bishop a1 that is
possible
well that's true I can go here though I
mean I'm so lost it
really okay
hi Scottie Selma that sets of pain okay
and it was a bit too risky probably if
you don't have a clear knowledge of the
whole thing yeah seems that he if it was
kind of knowledgeable here I don't think
that this is so great if why does not
play d6 this is probably well it's funny
that the benoni is clearly deemed as an
inaccuracy which is probably not
completely wrong anyway lets him okay 26
I went Bishop a5 we should 396 I don't
know I really have no clue about the
theory so take take loopy 8c fire going
for for the long diagonal yeah I think
b6 was kind of look kind of normal
it should be too I could be that really
hates my position I mean I was thinking
that white is better but I wasn't really
like one plus five is kind of drastic
CHM
yeah III was lame that was that was kind
of clear it's probably a position where
you can afford some things yeah I
totally did not spot that 23 was just
not a government if I mean so I left a
g6 I am lost yeah oh babe sorry after
allowing this yeah in g6 I am lost best
move was Bishop g2 what because of God
this is kind of funny you think that
this is the end but the bishop eco is
kind of continuing I mean it said it's a
bad position but I'm not immediately
lost interesting so g6 and here the
engines has said this is stronger even
aware that's indeed also very painful
just a huge double attack on this and
this and I cannot move the knight as
there's Queen f7 checkmate oh my god I
came so Queen C free I mean the he is
blonde there is a blonde a I would
widest to totally winning
it's not really a blunder so take take
aged six
this was Luke c6 what but that would
basically give up the night right okay
it's just a pain okay six young smoking
just have never to kiss you just cannot
play this it's like it's just a complete
disaster
yeah that we five looked kind of long so
here he couldn't hear I can actually
take and take d5 oh my
hmm yeah I had the feeling that maybe
here there was something didn't feel
super convincing by one but now Dee
takes d5 is even here the engine gives
these six is winning so but
interestingly this is given as a mistake
I've got creature of 600 that would have
been really interesting because if I get
an ending
if I get an ending things are not clear
really not because those pawns on the
Queen side they can prove to be quite
dangerous and he doesn't really have
anything else he has to take now and now
and it's like everything is hanging so
you probably have to take and then it's
kind of that is the game yeah the
engines has equal probably the position
is not equal but there's no clue what it
is so that was my only real opportunity
in the game near the end you know yeah
can you do think you played it playing
it well I really should spot that Queen
d3 wasn't just like here I was just
simply not taking 95 into account I
understand that why it is probably
better here but better and like winning
immediately is this a different kind of
thing okay thanks a lot for watching bye
bye